hi in this video I'm going to solve
another question from IIT Jam
biotechnology and in its a basically
match column type question so we have to
match elements of column one with column
two and these question is mainly from
biophysics so a lot of chromatography
and gel electrophoresis so let's analyze
point by point and let's see how we can
face this kind of question and how we
can easily solve what are the tips and
tricks behind it so first there is
phenol agarose and phenol agarose is
exclusively mainly used for hydrophobic
interaction chromatography shake so if
you don't know about ick so go to my
playlist and watch the video so phenol
agarose would get match with option
three
now n int a matrix is very popular and
it is used for affinity chromatography
especially the hist AG protein
purification so an int matrix would go
to five and teammate is used mainly for
gel electrophoresis of proteins mainly
in SDS page so teammate is used in that
case and the silicon oil is widely used
as an anti foaming agent so this would
go to this so now we have solved all the
options but actually we don't need to
solve all the options if we just solve
this in int matrix it's matching with Q
is matching with v we would see from
these options that only one option has Q
5 so from that particular Q 5 we can say
this option is correct and now if we
cross check our options are correct but
this question was from IT champ 2013 I
think but these days they are
manipulating the options in more clever
way so that you have to know all the
correct matching or otherwise you can't
answer hope you enjoyed and hope this
video helped you please like and
subscribe thank you